y estamos ahora justamente con la
periodista los hanes niños y despacio
tok tok na quien radio canadá como estas
la rancia gracias por venir acá
explicarnos un poco que está sucediendo
porque queremos saber qué está pasando
en no acá actualmente y después
volveremos un poco al pasado pero bueno
actualmente hay que hay que entender un
poco en lo que pasó en el pasado es
decir hace 30 años que los proyectos de
desarrollo inmobiliario en las tierras
en litigio envenenan las relaciones
entre por una parte los mojan y por otra
parte la ciudad de oca esto es
particularmente cierto en aquellas de la
señora de la montaña
estas son tierras de 600 pies cuadrados
en el contado actual dt montan y es muy
importante decir lo que habían sido
prometidas a los mojones en el siglo 18
entonces este invierno un proyecto de
construcción de más o menos 160
habitaciones en esas tierras mismas fue
presentado en febrero a los a los
habitantes de boca los mossos no fueron
consultados así que el consejo de bandas
de cannes ataque y los
organizados amenazó a la compañía con
perseguirla legalmente en el caso de que
en que avanzara con dicho proyecto razón
por la cual fue finalmente abandonado el
proyecto y que quedó que fue pero que
dijo cuáles son las justificaciones del
alcalde de oca para presentar un
proyecto sin consultar a los mox bueno
lo que pasa es que el que el que
presenta el proyecto es el promotor el
promotor inmobiliario pero bueno con el
alcalde de lo que es pascal que vio el
él dice que él dice que él protege a sus
ciudadanos pues son ellos que pagan
impuestos sobre esas tierras en disputa
dice también que lo que el jefe séptimo
de cannes ataque está haciendo es
inmoral es ilegal es básicamente es una
guerra abierta entre los mossos y pascal
que vio y / que vio y el jefe simón
los mossos acusan el alcalde de actuar
en connivencia con los promotores
mobiliarios la otra cosa es que el
alcalde de oca también quiere que el
gobierno federal consulte a su municipio
en sus negociaciones con canes hasta que
hay que explicar que los mo hacks están
han estado en conversaciones durante más
de una década para obtener una
compensación financiera de ottawa el
gobierno federal reconoce la validez de
las reclamaciones de los mo box en la
seño
time de la cual estábamos de la cual
hablamos hace unos minutos
entonces les tendría que ofrecer ottawa
les tendría que ofrecer a los mox una
compensación que sería de varios
millones de dólares y eso es otro punto
conflictivo entre ok los mossos que
dicen nosotros nos recibimos un mango
del gobierno
de qué se quejan etcétera y está
compensaciones es importante decirlo
permite permitiría al consejo de bandas
recomprar el terreno es reclamado para
agrandar su territorio claro entonces es
una cuestión antigua y también que tiene
muchas aristas diferentes a muchos
ángulos desde el cual no se puede
abordarlo y actuar y atenta y actual es
exactamente pero como decíamos no es la
primera vez que este este territorio de
oca y los mojos están como en riñas en
disputas hace tiempo que esto comenzó y
decíamos 30 años hasta 30 años
exactamente lo hagan sí o sí muchas
gracias por ponernos un poco en contexto
muchas gracias hasta pronto